المعركه في السودان بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في اسبوعها الرابع
تداعياتها الانسانيه مستمره وتستمر معها
معاناه بعض الباحثين عن مخرج امن
هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر وفي احد
معسكرات الايواء تبرز معاناه طلاب
اليمنيين تملكتهم الحيره بعد ان طال
الانتظار
انا يعني طول الطريق قله الامكانيات
العدد اليمني كبيره جدا تم اجلاء نسبه
بسيطه منهم لا تتجاوز العشره بالمئه وسط
ضغط طلابي ويعني على على الحكومه اليمنيه
انها تقوم باجلاء الطلاب اليمنيين هذا
المركز تقوم عليه احدى منظمات المجتمع
المدني بمجهودات ذاتيه لا تخلو من صعوبات
كثيره عندنا صعوبات في المويه لكن الحمد
لله يعني ما مقصرين والناس الخيرين ما
مقصرين
وخمسه وخمسين شاب من طلبه اليمنيين
موجودين معانا بحسب الاحصائيات فان هناك
اكثر من الفي يمني يرغبون في المغادره
تمكنت السلطاته بالتنسيق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من اجلاء 450 شخصا عبر
سفن سعوديه السلطات السودانيه طلبت من
المبعوث الاممي في السودان السعي والعمل
على حل اشكالات الاجلاء للسوريين
واليمنيين على حد سواء ونرجو ان السيد
مبعوث الامم المتحده المتواجده الان في
بورسودان انه يعمل على حل مشكله السوريين
يا اما او اليمنيين بالاخص السوريين
اليمنيين يا اما اجلاهم الى الى الى
بلادهم ياهم الى اي بلد اخر يا اما
يعملون في معسكرات مع اللاجئين يكون خارج
الولايه وما نزع نزعه اليوم
الجاليه اليمنيه حالها كحال بقيه الرعايا
الاجانب في معايشه ظروف الحرب بين الجيش
والدعم السريع لكن الظروف اجلائهم اختلفت
عن غيرهم ووصفت بالمعقده والتي تحتاج الى
تدخل سريع لتسريع وتيره العمل عليها محمد
عثمان العربيه من مدينه البحر الاحمر شرقي
السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات